what's going on guys this is rob and in
this video we're going to talk about how
the marvel cinematic universe
needs the superior spider-man so here's
the thing superior spider-man is one of
these characters that is absolutely
needed in the marvel cinematic universe
and it's kind of interesting because
he's a version of spider-man that we
just haven't really seen before right
and here's here's the funny thing i
would go as far as to argue that a
superior spider-man film would actually
be better than any of the spider-man
movies that we've seen up to this date
but it also depends on how they handle
it as we know with the morbius film just
because a movie has a villain doesn't
mean it's going to be a good movie uh
we'll do a review on morbius
we'll do a review on that film so here's
the thing all right for those of you
guys who are unfamiliar with the
superior spider-man he's one of the most
interesting versions of spider-man that
exists in marvel comics so the idea
behind this it really kind of comes out
of a handful of different things in the
sense that it was a handful of like
backup stories or little moments that
were featured over the course of dan's
slot spiderman run but then it
ultimately came to a head in a story
called dying wish and what you would
basically learn is that dr octopus was
quite literally dying and so what he did
is he developed a piece of technology
that allowed him to body swap peter
parker and so in essence his mind went
into the body of peter parker and the
mind of peter parker went into the body
of dr octopus now ultimately when dr
octopus's body essentially died that
peter parker died along with it but the
way that marvel fixed this is they said
that there was a portion of peter
parker's psyche that actually remained
inside his own body and that doctor
octopus would communicate with it now
depending on who you're talking to some
people would argue that that's actually
dr octopus's conscience and that as dr
octopus began to become a good guy that
the psyche of peter parker actually
began to essentially fall back in the
sense that he was finally leading into
conscientious behavior and basically
becoming a good guy and therein is the
nature of why a superior spider-man
movie would be so cool the cool thing
about this is that we don't really need
to know the ins and outs of dr octopus
in order to make it work all we would
really need are his mannerisms now the
reality here is that if they were going
to make a movie about this they would
have doctor octopus already established
in the marvel cinematic universe if for
no other reason than the fact that it's
only a matter of time before we get them
that the mcu is going to have their own
version of dr octopus somewhere along
the line i mean we can all kind of agree
that's going to be the case right there
are some spider-man villains that are of
just such a level of popularity that we
know is only a matter of time before
they actually appear in any one
particular film and so with this whole
situation
having him established beforehand would
make it easier but just from alfred
molina's doctor octopus just because of
the fact that even people who never saw
the old sam remy movies likely went back
and watched them because of spider-man
no way home they would have a general
gist of his character the benefit of
superior spider-man and the way this
played out is that after dr octopus took
over the body of peter parker and if we
remove the element right once basically
peter parker's you know psyche
essentially took a backseat and more or
less disappeared that what dr octopus
began to do was actually transform that
initially it was one of these things
where he just kind of harped on the idea
that peter parker was painfully
ineffective as being spider-man that
quite literally peter would put on his
costume and he would just swing through
the cities of new york and try to stop
crimes wherever he found them or else
team up with the avengers or the x-men
or the fantastic four as part of the
future foundation but the reality here
is dr octopus was like there's so much
more that can be done here and so what
he did is he actually developed these
little tiny spiders that actually just
moved throughout the entirety of the
city they were eyes and ears everywhere
and what they would do is they would
alert him to when a crime was taking
place so he could get there because the
reality is that with peter parker he
couldn't save everybody because if he's
in midtown he has no idea that there's
some kind of a mugging is happening on
like the upper east side he doesn't know
that's taking place because he's not
there but with superior spider-man he
was everywhere at once by virtue of
these little spiders that he had so he
could race over to the other side or he
could prioritize which crimes needed the
needed his attention the most and then
respond accordingly now initially it was
one of these things where he was just a
dick right he was like a villain running
around in the body of peter parker he
didn't really you know beat up innocent
people i mean he kind of did to a degree
but one of the big significant things
that came out of this and it was a huge
revelation for us as readers is we
learned that spider-man was actually
pulling his punches that when dr octopus
gets into a fight with the scorpion who
at that point in time was actually in
possession of the venom symbiote uh what
ended up happening is a fight broke out
between the two during a kind of a
branding initiative called dark rain
where basically superior spider-man
punched the jaw off of scorpion now
again he was in possession of the venom
symbiote so the jaw healed itself
otherwise scorpion would be walking
around right now with a fake jaw
which would actually be kind of cool
right like a metal fake jaw with like
you know sharp little teeth things down
there and it would be it'd be pretty
legit but it was basically dr octopus
realizing that at like any point in time
peter parker could have beat them to
death
and he just chose not to right but he's
just that strong right that capable but
as time progressed what you actually saw
was dr octopus falling for a woman named
anna maria marconi and he actually fell
in love with her because of her
intelligence and this actually led to
him becoming a much softer gentler
version of the character that we knew so
much so that he actually ends up
becoming a superhero and so one of the
things that he does is he basically
takes his mind puts it to task and forms
a company called parker industries so
that when the events of superior
spider-man come to an end and peter
parker gets his body back he's basically
richer than tony stark he runs a
multi-national
multi-billion dollar fortune 500 company
and literally uses the technology of
that company to improve the world but
all that was because of the superior
spider-man now eventually marvel and did
it in a story called back to basics by
nick spencer but the important thing
here is that because of the superior
spider-man he basically made peter
parker better and more capable
as far as being a spider-man across the
city of new york now that's why this
would work so well is because for
someone like dr octopus and this is one
of the things that i think people loved
about spider-man no way home it was a
redemption arc for for alfred molina's
doctor octopus when we left off he was a
guy that was just a terrible person
right just committed some crimes and
while you did get a bit of a redemption
as far as like the ending of his his
place in the old sam remy spider-man
films you also got some redemption here
but it was almost kind of like the
marvel cinematic universe was basically
telling us no matter what happens he's
going to end up becoming a good guy so
now let's take the next step and let's
ask the question what would happen if
that kind of redemption arc happened
under the circumstances of him being in
the body of peter parker but we know
that like he always chastised peter in
the old sam remy films he always
chastised peter for like not coming to
his full potential and that was even a
bit of an on-running joke in spider-man
no way home when alfred molina talks to
tony maguire and they've been separated
for basically a decade or two and he
asked him like how are you doing and
peter says doing better right trying to
do better it's kind of hitting back to
that old sam raimi spider-man
relationship between the two where like
dr octopus was always telling peter
you're never living up to your potential
you can be better than what you are so
let's take that to task and let's
actually put him in a situation where if
peter isn't necessarily able to become
better himself he'll make him better now
there are a couple things to keep in
mind here this concept would work
phenomenal if it was alfred molina and
toby maguire that's where it would work
the absolute best and i know a lot of
you guys are probably like yeah like
alfred molina takes over the body of
peter parker and like like tony
maguire's spider-man that would be
amazing
and it would right i mean if i had my
choice of what version of spider-man and
peter parker end up engaging in the
storyline it would absolutely be alfred
molina's dr octopus and toby mcguire's
peter parker not even by a little bit by
like a mile right and they could
engineer any circumstance under which
that could happen but with tom holland
spider-man
we don't necessarily know if it would
work out that way because we haven't
been introduced to his version of dr
octopus yet he's interacted with alfred
molina in no way home but he doesn't
have his own doc ock and the bigger
issue here that you also have to contend
with is that that feeling of alfred
molina and toby maguire that's nostalgia
glasses right like 100 percent that's
nostalgia like we look back to like
those old spider-man days and it's just
like yes that would be phenomenal and it
would work together because we have like
a couple decades of history there that
we can kind of look back on as we look
back on those memories fondly for a lot
of you guys it was when you were first
getting into comics or first getting
into comic book movies because it was
the first time anybody made any that
were actually good outside of blade but
the thing about that is it kind of
creates a circumstance where it's like
it's not an honest opinion of the
situation i think that having a tom
holland spider-man basically end up
swapping bodies with his own doctor
octopus that would be intriguing but
again the reason why the alfred molina
and toby mcguire idea works as well is
not just because of the nostalgia
glasses but because of the fact that we
know what his doctor octopus is about
that's what made the original story so
impactful is because we knew that dr
octopus he'd been around for something
like 50 years by the time that story had
been written we knew what dr octopus was
about we knew that he did have a kind of
gentler side we saw that during the
original spider-man annual sinister six
story right where like he's literally
feeding tea and trumpets to aunt may and
betty brandt they have no idea that
they've been kidnapped he's like
charming and he's a gentleman but
basically they were kidnapped in order
to force peter to fight the other
members of the sinister six so we know
that like he has a gentler and a softer
side that you know that story combined
with just a ton of others built up and
is what made superior spider-man
significant that history is important
there and that history exists between
alfred molina and and toby maguire i
just don't necessarily see this idea of
sony resurrecting that universe just to
tell this story they could it's entirely
possible that they could and i wouldn't
be surprised if we see more of toby
maguire in the marvel cinematic universe
supposedly he's going to be in doctor
strange too but fan reception to like
toby and andrew was so huge that i feel
like they're not simply going to stop
there right they're like as soon as they
were all confirmed like as soon as we
saw them right andrew garfield jumps
through the portal rips his mask off and
the the pop right the scream in the
theaters was actually louder than it was
when you had tony maguire
at least where i was i don't know about
you guys but where i was people were
more excited to see andrew garfield i
think it's largely because it was just
enough disbelief to not know if it was
true but nonetheless right it's one of
those things where where we know we'll
see them again and so because of that
that reception there they're gonna pop
up right we're gonna have more stories
about them and so it's not that far of a
stretch to believe that sony might
resurrect the old raimi verse and give
us more stories involving like you know
what peter parker or what tony mcguire
looks like now it could be one of those
things when like alfred molina is sent
back to his universe he's sent back to
the wrong point in time he doesn't go to
when he's supposed to be like that
moment before he basically dies or
around that time that he was supposed to
die and that in turn he's actually
teleported to a future point in time and
maybe something happened with toby who
knows but whatever it is it leads into
superior spider-man bit of a stretch but
not entirely impossible i mean we're
literally dealing with movies where a
guy turns into a giant green rage
monster and grimace with a wrinkly chin
decided to blink out half the life of
the universe i think we're beyond having
discussions about is it a stretch
i think we're beyond that point so
regardless i want to know what you all
think down in the comments section let
me know what you guys think about all
this but we're going to bring this to an
end happy april fool's day thank you all
for watching i will catch you all later
peace